retour en salles de rédaction pour la
suite du 19/20 pagaille ce soir dans le
conflit des surveillants de prison passe
aux procédures de révocation
les grévistes bravent la loi jeu pierre
arpaillange ministre de la justice est
l'invité du 19/20 le frc l'opposition
serait mais résolue c'est ce qu'a
déclaré jacques chirac cet après midi
aux journées parlementaires du fr
arcachon en prônant l'union de
l'opposition football tirage au sort au
deuxième tour l'europe se durcit pour
les clubs français
paris saint germain affrontera la
juventus de turin pense à ce soir à
faire 3 vous donne rendez vous avec la
passion celle des pionniers de la
première radio privée radio carolin dans
quelques minutes un avant-goût de la
plus belle aventure de la radio diffusée
ce soir à 21h30 dans thalassa
mais d'abord les prisons ce matin sur
france inter michel rocard le premier
ministre réaffirme est avec force les
surveillants n'ont pas le droit de grève
eh bien il n'empêche qu'aujourd'hui
plusieurs centaines de surveillants ont
déposé leurs clés ouais ce soir la
tension est très vive dans une quinzaine
de prison les surveillants sont en grève
et les crs assurent la surveillance des
détenus dans six maisons d'arrêt l'envoi
de 118 lettre de révocation par la
chancellerie n'a rien arrangé
bien au contraire comme le point complet
sur ce conflit caroline signalé
l'unanimité
les personnels en service d'après midi
on refuse de monter en détention
l'unanimité ce soir c'est la grève total
dans une quinzaine de prison les
surveillants déposer les clés suivants
le mot d'ordre des syndicats
seuls les promenades et les repas sont
donc assurés le dépôt des plaies en
train de blocage total de l'appareil
judiciaire qu'il cédera le premier
gouvernement ou syndicats ce
durcissement de la grève intervient
juste après les déclarations du premier
ministre michel rocard qui rappelait ce
matin que les surveillants n'ont pas le
droit de grève
justifiant ainsi les révocations 118
révocation sont en cours 59 à lyon 59 à
la santé de paris beaucoup d'autres ont
été demandés aujourd'hui par des
directeurs régionaux
pour le gouvernement ces révocations
entre caractère définitif
les prisons les gardiens sont solidaires
et décidé d'aller jusqu'au bout célia
révocation il n'y a qu'une chose à faire
se serrer les coudes et aller jusqu'au
bout tous les personnels pénitentiaires
de surveillance devront être révoqué ne
laisserons pas nos collègues dans le
besoin pour les syndicats la levée de
ces révocations reste toujours un
préalable à toute reprise des
négociations il est clair que d'abord il
faut que nos camarades soient réintégrés
immédiatement et sans appel dans leurs
fonctions
il n'est pas normal qu'en face au
chantage comme ça personne ne veut céder
résultats sur le terrain et les crs ont
pris la place des gardiens dans de
nombreuses prisons pour assurer la
surveillance
mais le climat y est explosif les
détenus sont très agités et des
mutineries sont toujours à craindre ici
des images de strasbourg lors de la
promenade de ce matin alors que faire
les surveillants des baumettes à
marseille ont peut-être trouvé la
solution
une centaine d'entre eux est en congé
maladie la raison ils sont frappés par
une épidémie ravageuse alors ils n'ont
pas le droit de grève a rappelé ce matin
le premier ministre monsieur pierre
arpaillange ministre de la justice
ils n'ont pas le droit de grève mais
peut-on rester dans cette situation de
blocage très longtemps effectivement ils
n'ont pas le droit de grève et ils ont
pris la décision les syndicats ont pris
la décision de donner comme mot d'ordre
de déposer les clés
c'est à dire de terreur c'est à dire de
faire grève et de faire grève d'une
manière totale c'est à dire que non
seulement ils nantes ne s'assure pas que
les détenus peuvent être sorti de la
prison pour aller devant les tribunaux
par exemple ou peuvent être où ils
empêchent leur rentrée dans
l'établissement à la suite par exemple
donné qu'on ne juge d'instruction non
seulement ils n'assurent pas les
parloirs avec les familles ce qui est
déjà très grave mais également ils ont
décidé de ne plus s'occuper du tout des
détenus et de ne plus rentrer en
détention et c'est là quelque chose qui
est absolument impossible à m
ça veut dire qu'il est hors de question
s'asseoir que vous leviez les sanctions
prises à l'encontre les gardiens de
prison égoutter lorsqu'un surveillant
qui a un métier qui touche à l'exercice
d'une fonction publique comme celle
eh bien il doit accomplir son devoir
normalement et dans les garanties de ses
statuts n'ayant pas le droit de grève
il a l'obligation d'être présent dans
les établissements aux heures prévues
quitté l'établissement comme ils le font
c'est un véritable abandon de poste et
je voudrais dire que la détention
ce n'est pas une usine dans lequel il
peut y avoir des grèves dans lesquelles
les salariés peuvent partir ou rentrer
avec occupation là ils abandonnent
sciemment la détention alors qu'il y a
en face des détenus qui sont des
personnes de chair et de sang comme même
et qui risquent de se livrer à des
exactions comme on l'a vu notamment à
draguignan qui coûtent fort cher mais ce
n'est pas encore la seule chose c'est
que au cours de ses effets il peut y
avoir des violences qui sont commises
aussi bien sur le plan physique que sur
le plan moral
il y à des problèmes très très grave
l'état ne peut pas se désintéresser de
ce qu'il ya à l'intérieur d'une prison
et on ne peut pas abandonner les prisons
alors ce soir monsieur le ministre vous
le dit encore mieux que nous c'est la
pagaille dans les prisons françaises
eh bien c'est la pagaille à partir du
moment où les surveillants qui ont cette
charge et ce en à peu près 5000 en phr
seize mille en france vous pouvez pas
laisser pourrir cette situation on ne
peut pas laisser pourrir cette voûte ce
titre situation et on a fait appel
effectivement à des policiers à des
gendarmes à des crs a été très mal vécu
sa part les surveillants le gardien de
prison et que ce que vous voulez qu'on
fasse c'est peut-être mal vécu mais vous
croyez que c'est le rôle normal de ses
personnels que je viens de citer et qui
fonce de ça avec beaucoup de sens de
leur devoir et de l'honneur
vraiment ils ont autre chose à faire
vous savez il serait peut-être
préférable qu'il soit affecté à des
tâches de maintien de l'ordre ou
s'occuper des problèmes de la direccte
garde des sceaux monsieur arpaillange
c'est la troisième fois que les
surveillants de prison ont déclenché un
mouvement grave un mouvement est tendue
c'est dire que vous n'avez pas jusqu
alors trouvé le moyen de répondre aux
interrogations de leurs syndicats
égoutter ils ont reçu déjà beaucoup de
choses il ne faut pas croire que aussi
bien au mois d'octobre que doc au mois
de février dernier
il n'est pas eu des sommes importantes
et très substantielle et si on fait
l'addition de ce qui leur a été donné
c'est eux qui arrive en tête de ce qui a
été fait pour la fonction publique
en réalité ils sont se sont mis dans
l'esprit que il devait avoir la parité
avec la police les ça doit être un peu
gênant pour eux quand même de voir les
policiers venir faire leur travail alors
que eux se mettent à l'abandon de poste
parce que vous ne sentez pas un peu seul
monsieur arpaillange ce soir face à ce
conflit
on se sent toujours seule madame losc
aura des responsabilités à prendre
et croyez moi qu'elles sont graves et
elles sont lourdes également mais je
pense que je les assure avec l'accord du
premier ministre et de tout le
gouvernement est de cette manière là je
ne me sens pas isolés mais ça ne veut
pas dire que je ne sente pas
terriblement impliqués et à ce sujet je
voudrais pouvoir dire aux surveillants
qui m'écoutent de revenir à la raison de
ne plus suivre un mot d'ordre de cette
nature devant lequel le gouvernement n'a
pas le choix et en tout cas devant
lequel il ne peut pas transiger
je voudrais dire aux syndicalistes de ne
pas maintenir un mot d'ordre qu'ils
savent parfaitement illégal et dans
quelqu'un au jour où l'autre paiera le
prix
une erreur a peut être été commise vu
leur demande de revenir sur cette erreur
le plus rapidement possible d'assurer le
travail normal celui pour lesquels ils
ont été engagés et sont rémunérés
je leur demande de faire cet effort est
de faire le plus rapidement possible et
il faut qu'il sache également que je
n'ai aucune animosité contre
comme j'ai une année contre quiconque
qu'il fasse cet effort qui retrouve la
voie du devoir et mes portes sont
ouvertes à nouveau devant te sera
capable de relancer monsieur nominer son
appel pathétique mais eux ils vous
disent d'abord lever les révocations je
ne peux pas le faire je viens de vous
dire que je n'ai pas le choix et le
moigne oliveira l'état ne désarment pas
que dirait le gouvernement que dirait la
majorité que dirait même l'opposition
sur l'essai
ce conflit se perpétuer les détenus
pouvant continuer ce qui c'était à
draguignan s'évader peut-être et mettre
en danger
quelquefois alors comment je le crains
la république monsieur en payant je vous
remercie vous parliez à l'instant de
l'opposition et bien d'arcachon
aujourd'hui où il ouvrait cette après
midi donc les journées parlementaires du
rpr jacques chirac a pris soin
semble-t-il de ne pas mettre d'huile sur
le feu vous confère le président du rpr
a préféré envisager toute autre chose
envisagez l'alternance politique mais
l'alternance grâce à l'union de
l'opposition une idée encore défendu cet
après-midi par jacques chirac
comment nous reconnaître dans une
politique de 30 menu ou le par les
doubles a rapidement remplacé le parler
vrai son d'arcachon le reportage de
patrick à cannes entre le psychodrame du
nude et f déchiré à vichy et la cohésion
d'un rpr serein d'arcachon le contraste
est totale le bon résultat aux
sénatoriales crée même une certaine
euphorie et l'agitation interne semble
terminée
les rénovateurs sont rentrés dans le
rang et n'ont pas fait imploser le
mouvement l'occasion est donc toute
trouvée pour le rpr de se présenter
comme la force principale est tranquille
de l'opposition qu'est ce que n'a pas
manqué de faire jacques chirac dans son
discours d'ouverture un jacques chirac
qui se veut le choc de file de
l'opposition toute entière et qui
n'hésite pas à faire la leçon à l'udf en
lui rappelant que appartenir à cette
opposition suppose une certaine rigueur
de comportement vis-à-vis du
gouvernement le président du rpr a bien
entendu
affirmer une opposition sereine mais
résolue nous ne pouvons pas approuver
une politique qui nous frappe
pav son manque d'ambition
comment en effet nous reconnaître si peu
que ce choix dans une politique de
trotte menu dans laquelle le par les
doubles a remplacé le parler vrai qui
devait en principe l'inspiré mais nous
avons le temps a conclu jacques chirac
qui compte sur les trois années à venir
sans élection pour pousser l'avantagé du
rpr et a filé une fois de plus son
nouveau profil d'homme d'état voilà donc
pour les journées parlementaires et
repère d'arcachon jean louis tixier
vignancour est décédé ce matin à
l'hôpital des invalides il était âgé de
81 ans
dès 1936 il mena de front une carrière
d'avocat est un combat politique qui
l'ont conduit à être le candidat de
l'extrême droite aux élections
présidentielles 1965 il venait à
l'époque de s'illustrer en prenant
position pour l'algérie française
il avait notamment défendu le général
salan ancien chef de l'oas
mais aussi bastien thiry le chef du
commando qui avait tenté de tuer le
général de gaulle dans l'attentât du
petit clamart à l'étranger une dépêche
vient de nous apprendre que 20 tonnes de
cocaïne ont été saisis aujourd'hui à los
angeles 20 tonnes je dis bien ce qui
représente un trafic d'environ 13
milliards de francs mais tout de suite
les télégrammes de l'étranger à
commencer par un choc politique
inattendue en pologne comme mon père
sophie guyot
aussi insensé selon le bon vieux
principe qui aime bien châtie bien
lech walesa a lancé aujourd'hui un ferme
avertissement au gouvernement mazowiecki
pour ce président de solidarité
réagissez au plan d'austérité présenté
hier devant le parlement
et il a brandi la menace d'une explosion
sociale si la hausse des prix continue
est la yougoslavie en ébullition près de
cinquante mille personnes ont défilé à
novi sad dans le nord est du pays
les manifestants protestent contre
l'adoption mercredi dernier d'une
nouvelle constitution en slovénie qui
renforcerait l'autonomie de cette
république
la manifestation organisée avec le
soutien des autorités politiques locales
a appelé à l'intervention de l'armée et
en slovénie
journée calme à manille au lendemain de
la mort de ferdinand marcos
par précaution l'armée et la police ont
été mises en état d' alerte mais les
manifestations réclamant le retour du
corps aux philippines sont restées
pacifiques
de son côté la présidente correia qui
nous a fait mettre les drapeaux en berne
mais elle maintient son refus de
rapatrier la dépouille de l'ancien
dictateur continue de jouer les vedettes
américaines en scope et en technicolor
mais si liens commencent à s'inquiéter
le réveil du volcan semble s'accentuer
chaque jour et il s'accompagne
maintenant de secousses sismiques
pour l'instant les habitations ne sont
pas menacés mais le ministre italien de
la sécurité civile s'est dit prêt à
toute éventualité
si espi football coupe d'europe au soir
de la toussaint il serait absolument
fantastique que les cinq clubs français
soit encore tous en course en effet le
tirage au sort du deuxième tour ce midi
à zurich qui a été beaucoup moins
favorable que celui du premier le gros
lot il est pour le paris saint-germain
la juventus avec match retour qui plus
est à turin dur dur aussi pour sochaux
face à la fiorentina et pour monaco
contre les allemands de l'est du dynamo
de berlin et puis la tâche sera sûrement
beaucoup plus facile pour marseille qui
rencontrera les grecs de la e40
d'athènes et surtout pour auxerre qui
devraient s'assurer la qualification
face aux finlandais de rovaniemi ce
match aller le 18 octobre donc les
matches on retrouve le 1er novembre
en tennis je vous souhaite d'avoir pu
cet après midi en direct à 16h sur l'a3
à suivre ce match de quart de finale du
passing shot de bordeaux entre ivan
lendl et henri leconte malheureusement
pour henri leconte tout juste
convalescent et bien lendl et est resté
le numéro un mondial
il a gagné lisent en deux sets 6-2 6-3
exit donc henri leconte il ne
participera pas aux demi finales il
reste pourtant un français en course
jean-philippe florian qui affrontera et
1916 en direct bien sûr sur fr3 donc
demain sur l'a3 les deux demi-finales du
passing shot de bordeaux lendl isa gars
et emilio sanchez contre florian vous
l'avais dit la fortune sous les pas d'un
cheval c'est ce qu'espère l'inventeur en
mayenne
fer à cheval absolument révolutionnaire
il est en aluminium
beaucoup plus léger et paraît-il
beaucoup plus agréable pour les chevaux
résultat la petite entreprise croule
sous les commandes et devant les marchés
à l'étranger un reportage fr3 le mans j
pal serre mais dessert français et
surtout révolutionnaire tellement
révolutionnaire qu'ils viennent d'entrer
au galop sur le marché américain
hypo matelas société lavalloise qui les
a conçus garde jalousement le secret de
fabrication
normal des milliers d'alliages ont été
tentées avant de trouver le bon on sait
seulement qu'il y à 140 modèles qu'ils
sont en aluminium donc plus léger
seulement 100 g soit trois fois moins
que les faire traditionnels en acier
défaire sans faire qui évite
l'échauffement et ne moisit spa le sabot
autant de qualités qui aboutissent
fourie pommade à un contrat
d'exclusivité avec une des cinq
premières entreprises du secteur aux usa
le faire porte décidément bonheur
l'entreprise qui emploie 23 personnes
chaud c'est déjà les cracks france a
depuis 1982 désormais ce sont cent mille
exemplaires qui sortent chaque année
qu'il est loin le temps où le pdg
diplomates n'était qu'un prp en
quincaillerie tout de suite que le tour
de france de l'actualité grâce aux
images de nos stations régionales comme
mon père jean paul girouard
après henri krasucki hier c'était au
tour aujourd'hui d' andré lajoinie de
visiter les grévistes de peugeot le
président du groupe communiste à
l'assemblée nationale a annoncé qu'il
déposerait lundi une proposition de loi
portant le smig à 6500 francs
à ce jeu comme à mulhouse la journée
d'aujourd'hui a été marquée par un
retour au calme après les vives tensions
d'hier la production a légèrement monter
en cadence malgré une petite
augmentation des grévistes
je me demande s'il n'y a pas un étrange
malentendu répression de pierre
bérégovoy à propos du conflit qui
l'oppose aux agents des impôts
selon le ministre des finances le
dialogue n'a jamais été rompu avec son
personnel et il ne le sera pas il a
toutefois rejeté la demande
d'augmentation de 600 francs mensuels
des grévistes découverte de l'arsenal
des auteurs des attentats contre des
foyers sonacotra de la côte d'azur 100
kg de matériel 7500 pièces de munitions
du plastique des grenades
le tout caché dans le bateau du frère du
chef présumé des poseurs de bombes
nicolas rouge michel gouges et deux
complices ont été inculpés et écroués
ces attentats contre des foyers
sonacotra avait fait un mort et 16
blessés en 1990
de la musique avec un orchestre normal
mais aussi avec des poids de poètes et
des tic tac tic tac c'était la figure
imposée à deux jeunes compositeurs pour
la semaine des arts et techniques de
l'automobile de clermont ferrand
l'orchestré de chambre d'homère ligne à
exécuter l'oeuvre en cinq jours et demi
en des joueurs de klaxon du clignotant
et d'essuie glace et comment création il
ne faut jamais rien négliger les
voitures utilisées étaient déférés
mustang et autres camilla c'est quand
même plus chic au niveau sonore
il n'y a pas d'âge pour se jeter à l'eau
mais l'autre même lorsqu'il s'agit des
eaux tumultueuses du gave d'oloron et de
débuter le rafting à 60 18 ans mais
cette aventure un groupe du 3ème âge a
choisi de la vivre ironie du sort c'est
le très jeune moniteur qui a été épaté
par le dynamisme et le courage de ces
stages est un reportage du jeune
dominique lagarde
une première pour ces personnes du
troisième âge
retraité de saint quentin de la ville de
genève une première aussi pour leurs
guides le troisième âge n'est pas le
public habituel des eaux vives du gave
d'oloron un troisième âge pas comme les
autres et non plus habitués aux
expériences nouvelles et aux activités
diverses et lola kayak ou ski
c'est bizarre on va voir comment ils
vont faire
premiers coups de rames et bientôt
première appréhension
roche l'internât joyeuse de passage que
mourad et doré ou des kings
puis viennent les premiers rapides
vraiment impressionnant
del nido après 24 km beau sport mais
surtout de bonne humeur c'est l'arrivée
sur sauveterre de béarn sinsat sionnel
formidable si présent il était vraiment
un cadeau cette journée un cadeau donc
offert par le 19/20 sur le gave d'oloron
depuis le 19 août dernier radio caroline
m'aimait plus radio carolin disent les
britanniques
l'ancêtre des radios libres planté
depuis 25 ans en mer du nord a été
arraisonné le 19 août par les garde
côtes néerlandais avec ce silence radio
c'est tout un symbole qui disparaît 25
ans de la radio pirate et musical qui a
eu jusqu'à 20 millions d'auditeurs la
plus belle aventure de la radio retracer
ce soir à 21h30 dans thalassa
voici tout de suite un avant goût de ce
reportage signé isabelle meubles et
jean-michel des stands pour les images
carolin est ami ancrée depuis 25 ans en
mer du nord au large des côtes
britanniques
elle est la pionnière des radios de pop
music la seule rescapée des stations de
haute mer d'europe
carolin capté en angleterre sur le
littoral français belges et hollandais
l'histoire de la radio shore est une
épopée un combat incessant contre vents
et marées contre les états européens
aussi qu'ils ont déclaré hors la loi en
67 pour échapper à tout contrôle
carolin s'est réfugié dans les eaux
internationales une zone maritime hors
de toute juridiction un espace de
liberté que les autorités néerlandaises
ont pourtant sciemment violé le 19 août
dernier
depuis le n'aviez de carolin et
silencieux il ne le restera sans doute
pas longtemps en 25 en rien une personne
n'a pu faire taire les turbulents
flibustiers des ondes radio carolin et
al assad donc à 21h30 ce soir sur l'a3
ensuite soir 3 présenté par nagui
gilbert toutes les infos bien sûr merci
de votre attention bonsoir église et à
demain commencera demain
bon
il dit
et